[Music]  [Music]  the time going by the natural theme is  wear floral out-group so because we  could do with some natural part  materials when the cones and the  speculum mr. optimist colors of blue and  gold so decided that with the blue stars  that we had made that we could combine  them and make an angel so this tree it  has been put together by eco educate in  youth space team at renewer  and these toys would have all gone to  landfill as people come up they can put  a gold coordination and then that gives  them a right to choose which tree and  all the proceeds go to defibrillator for  the Town Hall and then the rest of the  money goes to st. John's